you look very good today enjoy this
episode - para back so this is us
arriving to the base let's get me the
lie now what we find the condenser
destroy it and get out and any idea how
you plan to do that no but we gotta hear
something it's out here - um oh [ __ ]
what did I know of an unscheduled or
unconfirmed submarine approach or
whatever it just doesn't make sense to
me that they would have noticed this
right away
Jodi don't get too close to them can't
just wait here hi tenza
folks Adi don't watch she but what's the
point of in trying if we know we're
gonna get caught anyway you know
oh I didn't get tada Jody what's
happening
Wow
then that's weird
oh I get to I'm free
free ballin
I can't go through some walls that's
[ __ ] come on well I'm gonna kill you
I have been visible dark waiting why did
I do that
right I kill him
I was really really for no reason at all
except with this
being able to do it Triforce sell-by get
any let's be this guy kill people
dubstep hot hot it's a joke gosh imam
khomeini submission oh [ __ ]
cute well to turn off July
sorry sorry sorry I'll cord it's don't
touch me okay alright there's a gun in
there though so that's perfect
where you going sir where you going
you can't go hey you just can't go babe
I didn't I need you oh geez I'm working
on it I'm being Asian and [ __ ] I'll be
there in a second all right
there's a gun there why don't you take
it take the gun
take the gun now right there's another
kind of you cool bigoted fat ass every
mother phone in here
hi hi hi guys steer like away my side
no well [ __ ] you my moustache is your
bestest
whoa did the bullet ricochet Oh
damn damn see you
I was not away for more than 10 seconds
I can so much damage me
did we do it
why oh there's another one here and see
it
yep quick get me out of here
yes so what was your plan anyway just go
down there and get yourself killed
geez damn he's strong [ __ ] man Ryan no
[ __ ] that guy come on let's go
you
right
is that Ryan
I fix the door
can you walk
Hey look go back to the subs wait for me
if I'm not back in 15 minutes just go
without me
you're crazy you're joining me done at
the base is destroyed let's get out of
here but we still can
roost is wide open entities are just
gonna come pouring out if we don't close
it oh it's too late Jodi we gotta go now
it's all the way you know
Portia's going
explosives irrigation
am I supposed to find issues I need the
explosives and interrogations thank you
I heard you the first time I had the
[ __ ] bus wasn't over the
interrogation room
god hey calm down
I'm Thunder mostly you know I could just
kill you right faster died hi would you
like to die I'll tell you everything I'm
alright
running a fine
we're gonna blow this [ __ ] up I don't
know what I don't know what do you want
to blow up you tell me
what's this it's not a diving suit
[ __ ] boots are made for walking
that's what I called some hardcore scuba
diving Alex badass Manny how does she
know he's scared I think someone was a
bit inspired by that shitty movie with
alien words prayer that was like the
only good part it's the reason why
everyone saw it
like I know wearing helmet
fine attach black there's gotta be a
light on this thing yeah got it
all right this is actually very cool
very dead space's
yeah I appreciate how beautiful this
game is even in its dark mum I'm saying
I don't know
wherever I'd really don't know where
we're going all I know is we're gonna
blow something up
hi there sorry I sweat it today on isn't
it Thanks
can't move forward to something
oh they're to go there
it's gonna blow up the other world is
that it no that's mechanism
where the hell am I going
but we only have 15 minutes to
we got to find one um all of them
how did she know these explosive works
underwater
I guess if you know how to work a
submarine you probably know that [ __ ]
too
oh [ __ ] what's that okay you know I know
I'm very vulgar I don't make a lot of
perverted jokes but that riff looks like
a vagina this is all I'm saying
all right three minutes
three minutes cheese girl knows are you
better pick up your pace
Oh
oh I know oh it's like one of those deep
fishy faces
oh it's battling
oh [ __ ] run
it's that it's that [ __ ] thing from
Super Mario 64 [ __ ] that thing scare the
[ __ ] out of me oh I'm not gonna let you
have your fun with me again I'm old now
and less frightened not true but I am
old
goddammit climb up the ladder
go up Jody I'm holding down to go up
what the [ __ ] well that was surprisingly
easy
hey em oh [ __ ] this place is leaking I
would keep the suit on if I were you
you're going to die here with me how
kritis cover me hurt the word as
evernote destroyed because I really feel
American [ __ ] which way that way yeah
no no slap me yes this one's biggest
weakness flaps yes oh sure
oh oh no no
this is gotta go which way that way that
way
see I'm nailing it now
you know this place Sparkle crash
which way that way yes
sack yep keep slapping the floor I don't
know why not tell your wife if the games
in the batter they yell the line you
never fight a pleasure
you never cut the quick use you're
staying over sad be able to again bought
a Mac for the boy the way he give it
won't be put off macaque a trip I'd
agree sorry sorry I just get really into
it which way
I push the ride I guess that's what
wasn't right get it I was not even until
I sincerely apologize what are you doing
this
Wow why didn't I didn't do anything sir
I'm in
I guess that fish won again
oh the fish is after me now
I don't remember which way it is that
let me right
Barbra's
five
you know don't [ __ ] touch me
Jesse swine that's right
Canadian flag what the [ __ ]
Oh what are we going this way yes
yeah
duck always lies
oh [ __ ] that's gotta be you gotta you
gotta you got a [ __ ] night right away
right I'm right she better be glad that
she's got to go right
because our balls will be inside her
body yet I guess they would be the same
I'm just saying if it's - point
what am i doing come on Jodi come on
keep running
even know where you're going
she left he left
is it still there no he [ __ ] left of
course damn it Ryan he was a sucker you
I know he's probably laughing his ass
huh
you think I let you down huh yeah I did
I really [ __ ] dead and you know why
you know why because he can't drive the
submarine without me that's the only
[ __ ] reason it is it's the only
reason I'm the same deadly living with
that catchphrase [ __ ] Ryan hashtag [ __ ]
ride freighter that's it
the [ __ ] I don't know right
that's what [ __ ] happened do you
think I made a kidding I should kill the
Boosters
go out and swim and push cry and reach
we're gonna try out no no
I'm not far from the surface maybe we
can make it to the top my life yeah
sound like [ __ ] good plan
really that's their [ __ ] plan Avni
she has the suit
Ryan's gonna [ __ ] freeze his nipples
off dude how are you okay she's doing it
got it got it
what about Ryan that's right I mean I
hate him at all but [ __ ]
I'm not saying this would be perverted
but her nipples kick has to be diamonds
right now
I got I gotta say holy [ __ ] that guy is
a Viking
really
the house is right there I would be like
fire okay serenity I okay we made the
right choice I did the same thing still
angry with me
no god damn it Ryan god damn it god damn
it
sorry babe like an absolutely
got no don't I never time to tell you
this but
my love you Johnny God
diamond but
want you to know just in case we die
here
damnit right
so how about you yeah
to
by yeah
yeah great
just
while I know ash see you on the other
side
[ __ ] Titanic moment you know there's
a fireplace about know 50 meters from
name god damn I hate writing even more
now there with that [ __ ] to me god damn
ear Annie damn ear a me dub hope Raimi
dies they don't even give a [ __ ]
well I guess whoa are we going back all
the way to the beginning so how does she
get into the goddamn this is so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on I don't even know
an eye for an eye
alright okay boss boss god damn it
alright
hope you boys enjoyed this episode god
damn it Cammy I'll see you in the next
one like you don't enjoy watching house
metal I appreciate order but DNA okay
blood blood
Jeff is on his way done